je vous propose
de débuter cette après-midi par un
amendement
important qui est une proposition pour
remettre en cause le
soutien
aveugle qui est apporté par le
gouvernement
notamment sur aux consommateurs
d'électricité ce qui est la reconduction
qui est proposée évaluée à 10 milliards
nous paraît devoir être remise en cause
en introduisant des mesures de
ciblage d'ailleurs on n'est pas tout à
fait les seuls à penser qu'il y a un
travail à faire que ce soit l'agence de
coopération des régulateurs de l'énergie
qui euh a évalué les différentes mesures
et nous sommes le pays le deuxè pays
dans le bloc européen euh à avoir
mobilisé le plus de moyens le Conseil
d'analyse économique ne dit pas autre
chose et d'ailleurs la Commission
européenne a également dans les données
qu'elle a fourn elle avait invité
puisqu'elle n'est pas là pour inciter
les la France à sortir de ces
dispositifs d'aide non
ciblé c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'amendement que je présente
enentend d'une part annuler la
reconduction sans distinction de la
minoration d'accise sur l'électricité
c'est pour les particuliers pour
substituer pour lui substituer une aide
ciblée renforcée sur les ménages
modestes les classes moyennes cette aide
prendra la forme d'un chèque énergie qui
sera introduit en deuxème partie par un
amendement déposé par notre collègue
Christine Lavarde je dis d'ailleurs que
cet amendement à pro objectif donc
d'introduire un dispositif qui sera
cette fois ciblé qui sera évidemment
moins coûteux pour les finances
publiques de l'ordre de un bon milliard
d'euros d'économie ce qui n'est pas rien
monsieur le ministre je crois nous avons
souvent fait des propositions ici au
Sénat en demandant un ciblage sur les
aides on a rarement pour ne pas dire
jamais été entendu on vous donne là une
occasion de suivre une piste de mesures
d'économie merci monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le
ministre
merci Monsieur le le Président Monsieur
le le rapporteur général votre votre
amendement soulève un sujet important
pour nous vous savez que
pendant et pour faire face à la crise
énergétique et protéger les Français
nous avons de manière temporaire baissé
considérablement la taxe qui s'applique
sur sur
l'électricité qu aujourd'hui en vigueur
désormais à 1 € par mgaw votre
amendement propose de porter cette taxe
la titicfe de 1 € aujourd'hui à 32 €.
euh nous allons et j'aurai l'occasion de
présenter un amendement différent du
votre monsieur le le rapporteur général
pourquoi nous avons au fond deux
solution je crois entre la piste que
vous esquissez et celle que je vais
défendre dans dans quelques quelques
quelqu minutes nous partageons comme
vous la nécessité de sortir
progressivement des dispositifs de crise
il en va de la bonne gestion de nos
finances publiques et il en va aussi
tout simplement de la normalisation de
nos pratiques en matière tarifaire et de
gestion publique deux options pourquoi
la vôre monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur général compte tenu de ce que
l'on sait de l'évolution des tarifs
réglementés sur les électricité qui
devrait conduire à une révision à la
hausse de 2 % à comptter de de février
avec la hausse que vous prévoyez
monsieur le le rapporteur général la
taxe le prix de l'électricité en février
pourrait probablement bondir de près de
20 % de 20 % monsieur le le rapporteur
général dès le mois de de février et
vous nous dites en contrepartie de ça
vous allez créer un chèque exceptionnel
pour limiter l'impact de cette haosse je
le dis très significative 20 %
d'augmentation avec un chèque
exceptionnel dont j'ai bien entendu à
l'instant monsieur le rapporteur général
que vous dit qui va couvrir les classes
moyennes également alors vous
savezy classe modeste et moyenne et vous
savez que le chèque exceptionnel que
nous avions fait verser en 2023
représentait un coût de près de 2
milliards d'euros et allit jusqu'au 4e
descil 4e descil c'est pas les classes
moyennes donc le chèque que vous
proposez est un un chèque qui va coûter
extrêmement cher d'ailleurs je suis
preneur du de l'évaluation que vous
faites du chèque pour comprendre donc
d'un côté vous allez faire bondir le
prix de l'électricité au-delà des 10 %
nous avons pris l'engagement avec le
gouvernement qu'il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
au-delà de 10 % en février et donc nous
proposons la chose suivante par rapport
à à l'amendement du rapporteur général
au lieu de faire bondir la taxe de 1 € à
32 € on souhaite ramener euh le tarif de
l'électricité à mi-chemin la taxe pardon
à mi-chemin dans le respect de
l'engagement du plafond de 10 %. et ça
ça nous permettrait d'une part de faire
des économies et puis de protéger le
reste des Français d'une augmentation
trop importante et d'un autre côté vous
vous prévoyer une un un un un
bondissement mais avec un chèque moi je
crois qu'il faut sortir progressivement
des chècs et je vous ai entendu souvent
les uns les autres en disant faut faut
sortir de la politique d'échec et donc
je pense qu'il est plus raisonnable de
dire on augmente progressivement la
fiscalité sur l'électricité ne pas
dépasser les 10 % c'est très important
de pas dépasser ces 10 % c'est
l'engagement que nous av pris et éviter
de reconstituer des checs qui seront par
ailleurs très coûteux donc je crois au
final monsieur le le rapporteur général
que nous pouvons viser avec ce que nous
proposons le même objectif d'économie
mais sans l'échec sans le chque et sans
j'allais dire augmenter les prix de
l'électricité au-delà de de 10 % j'ai
essayé de de résumer un peu les deux
alternatives entre les deux amendements
qui se présentent à vous donc c'est une
demande de retrait sur votre amendement
au bénéfice de l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui pour terminer pardon ce
long détour mais je pense que c'est un
sujet très important qu'on prenne le
temps de de bien en débattre qui nous
permet d'augmenter les taxes mais pas
au-delà de 10 % des prix d'électricité
et sans réactiver un nouveau chèque un
nouveau
chèque monsieur le rapporteur
général alors Monsieur le Ministre
finalement vous proposez de garder des
dispositifs non
ciblés c'est le fameux quoi qu' en
coûte d'ailleurs quand il y a un nouvel
acronyme qqc ça fait qu et vous en
demandez à chaque fois on met une
tranche de plus 10 milliards ce qu'on
vous propose nous c'est de cibler on
cible sur si décil les six premiers
déciles
c'est donc
ciblé et en fait vous ce que vous faites
vous faites une suppression globale quel
que soit le niveau pour toutes les
cibles de revenu ce que nous proposons
c'est de modifier en première partie
pour apporter dans la seconde partie
c'est ce qu'on vous a dit des chèqus
parce que leschec quel quels atouts ils
vont présenter c'est qu'en fonction des
revenus dans les très bas décil ils
seront plus élevés que ce que vous
imaginez aujourd'hui dans les déciles 4
5 6 ils seront équivalents et ceux des
Français qui ont les revenus les plus
élevés et bien ils n'auront pas
d'aide parce que nous pensons qu'il faut
progressivement sortir du dispositif et
quand je dis ils n'ont pas d'aide c'est
parce que nous avons des choix à faire
chacun peut faire c arbitrage les
ménages les plus modestes souvent n'ont
pas de choix qu'ils soi propriétaire ou
locataire et vous le savez parce que
finalement il cumulle des situations
difficiles passoir thermique précarité
économique et souvent sociale là on doit
mettre l'accent le plus important et
dans les ménages chez les ménages les
plus aisés ça relève plus de l'arbitrage
personnel et ce qu'on a déjà expliqué
bah oui en fonction de ses conditions de
vie et de de ses revenus je crois qu'on
doit envoyer un message qui est la
responsabilisation merci donc
l'amendement est
maintenu monsieur
gu merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre il y a pas que deux
alternatives il y en a TR il y a la
votre celle qui a coûté 42 milliards
d'euros avec le bouclier tarifaire et le
rapporteur a raison une aide qui n'est
pas ciblée et qui a été directement dans
la poche des énergéticiens qui d'une
main droite on augmenter les tarifs 15 %
en 2022 25 % en 2023 10 % annoncé en
2024 et de l'autre côté ont touché 42
milliards d'euros par les impôts et donc
le consommateur il espolié deux fois une
première fois sur sa facture et une
deuxième fois en tant évidemment que
contribuable mais la deuxième chose la
deuxème alternative qui nous est proposé
par monsieur le rapporteur elle n'est
pas bonne non plus pourquoi parce que si
on venait à voter cet amendement il y a
un problème c'est que vous mettez un
coin dans le tarif réglementé de
l'électricité que vous et c'est c'est
bien explicité y compris dans
l'amendement si on venait à voter ça
volerit en éclat le tarif réglementé
l'électricité et alors là tout serait au
marché et d'ailleurs on a un problème
c'est que aujourd'hui le marché européen
de l'énergie il ne rapproche pas le prix
du coût de production il est
complètement décorrélé c'est une
inflation qui ne repose sur rien à part
le trading donc on vous propose une
troisième alternative et on continuera à
vouloir proposer dans la deuxème partie
du PLF c'est qu'il faut nationaliser
l'ensemble du secteur énergétique et
revenir à un monopole public parce que
nous considérons que l'énergie est un
bien commun et un bien essentiel pour
lap population et qu'il doit être sorti
des griffes du marché et donc comme ça a
été fait juste après après guerre voilà
où nous en sommes sinon nous
continuerons à débourser des milliards
et des milliards d'argent public qui
seront absorbés par les grands groupes
en réalité pour verser des dividendes je
vous remercie merci Monsieur Guay la
parole est à Monsieur danteek
oui merci monsieur le Président nous
allons voter cet amendement je crois que
c'est un amendement intéressant qui
distingue euh les ménages précaires les
classes moyennes et les et les plus
riches a presque tendance a c'est un
amendement un peu de gauche euh donc
nous allons le soutenir et un un un
autre argument en ce sens c'est aussi
d'insister sur le fait que quand on
regarde le système de ma prime renve
aujourd'hui euh il est totalement euh
fait pour accompagner les ménages euh
modestes et sans rentrer dans tout le
débat on l'aura un autre moment euh on
voit que finalement euh les plus aisés
qui ont ont le plus de capacité
finalement à investir dans dans la
rénovation finalement le font pas
obligatoirement l'autre raison pour
qu'elles investissent c'est que le prix
de l'énergie soit soit plus élevé donc
c'est un amendement qui va aussi dans le
sens d'amener les classes C aller plus
rapidement sur leur rénovation et leur
efficacité énergétique nous voterons cet
amendement merci Monsieur DCH madame
Lavarde oui merci j'aurais bien voulu
que le ministre partage avec nous ses
calculs parce que je l'ai bien écouté
j'ai du mal à comprendre comment les
tarifs qui si jamais on ne fait rien
c'est-à-dire en prenant que l'évolution
entre guillemets des des prix de marché
devrait faire 2 % si on maintenait la
même assise en février si jamais on
remonte l'assise on fait une hausse de
20 % j'ai étis regardé un peu la
décomposition du prix avant tous les
mécanismes de de de tarif qui est donc
en en 2021 on avait une part de la
fiscalité qui n'est pas dans les
proportions qui permettent de obtenir 20
% de Haus ce mois de février en fait je
vous pose toutes ces questions parce que
je suis un peu échaudée par les
estimations qui ont été faites l'année
dernière au moment où on discutait des
tarif de l'énergie et des différentes
taxes et rentes et autres où on nous a
vendu n'importe quoi on nous a même
demandé parfois de refaire des secondes
délibération parce que là vous nous
annoncez une hausse des prix qui me
semble très supérieure à ce qu'on peut
obtenir en faisant vite fait des des des
produits en croix par rapport à la
décomposition du prix et aussi vous nous
annoncez un montant du chaque énergie
exceptionnel
pour des sommes très excédentaires à ce
que nous nous avons pu chiffrer en
prenant la consommation moyenne des
ménages français en faisant ensuite tout
ça en tenant compte de la composition
par du nombre de personnes dans les
foyers et autres donc je voilà je
j'avoue que c'est très difficile pour
nous de de de se prononcer puisque vous
nous annoncez des chiffres mais on sait
pas comment ils sont
calculés notre amendement est
l'amendement qui est en seconde partie
on maîtrise parfaitement ce qu'il y a
dedans mais notre estimation est très
différente de la vôtre
monsieur le rapporteur général enfin
Monsieur le Ministre enfin c'est bien on
fait un peu de technique mais je
rappelle juste que on peut parler et
intervenir sur ce sujet parce qu'on a
proposé de de ramener l'article qu'on
évoque là en première partie sinon on le
voyait passer ni vu ni
connu et on ne pouvait rien faire voilà
donc après nos no collègues nous ont dit
tout à l'heure que l'amendement était un
peu de gauche moi je vais vous dire
enfin j'ai j'ai jamais vu j'ai pas vu
souvent la gauche proposer des
amendements avec des économies d'un peu
plus d'un milliard
hein et puis et puis oui oui vous l'avez
fait voilà et Monsieur le Ministre quand
même je je j'ai j'ai revérifié euh les
propos du du ministre de l'économie qui
qui remerciait dans son propos
introductif vous étiez d'ailleurs à sa
gauche et c'est bien naturel
je le remercie je remercie le rapporteur
général pour cette proposition qui me
semble bonne utile intéressante et
justifiée donc vous êtes en train dire
qu'elle est mauvaise inutile
inintéressante et injustifiée non c'est
dommage allez monsieur le ministre
rapidement si vous pouvez monsieur le
Président j'essaie d'être le plus rapide
possible mais on est quand même là au au
cœur de d'un des moments très importants
aussi du PLF donc je je ve prendre quand
même le temps d'expliquer d'abord redire
ce que j'ai dit au rapporteur général
j'ai dit sénatrice Lavin
c'est très bien et nous le posons avec
vous la question de la sortie
progressive des dispositifs
exceptionnels et ça se traduit par quoi
c'est-à-dire qu'on a quasiment supprimer
la fiscalité dit
ticfe je repose le débat ce que vous
proposez et sur laquel nous disons avec
Bruno Le Maire c'est bien ça va dans
dans le bon sens et dans le sens que
nous souhaitons également aller et donc
une forme de convergence nous souhaitons
sortir de ces dispositifs exceptionnels
voilà la raison c'est qu'on n pas tout à
fait d'accord mais c'est pas très grave
on voit bien que l'intention la partage
sur la manière de le faire nous on
propose la chose suivante on dit on ne
peut pas demander aux Français de
supporter une hausse de 20 % de
l'électricité je réponds à Christine
Lavarde il va y avoir d'après nos
estimations ça peut bouger le trve selon
les données dont on dispose en février
2024 devrait augmenter de 2 à 3 %
maximum bon si on fait l'augmentation de
35 € je vérifie c'est bien 32 32 pardon
32 € ça va porter à peu près le
prixélectricité à une augmentation de 20
%. 20 % si vous mettez 2 % plus le TRV
nous on dit cette os elle est trop forte
trop importante trop rapide on ne dit
pas qu'il ne faut pas sortir à terme de
ce dispositif exceptionnel on le dit
juste que la marge que vous proposez
pour février elle est trop importante
nous avons pris l'engagement mais il
peut y avoir un désaccord entre nous de
ne pas porter d'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité de plus de 10 % en février
vous nous demandez de faire 20 % je vous
dis non on ne veut pas aller aussi loin
parce qu'on pense que l'effort qui est
demandé au français est trop important
là où on se rejoint c'est qu'en terme
d'économie donc nous notre souhait c'est
faire cette osse modérée et vous voulez
faire une osse beaucoup plus forte 20 %
mais avec un chèque et je le dis à
monsieur le rapporteur général un chèque
pose pour moi deux difficultés la
première si on veut sortir
collectivement du quoi qu'il en coûte et
de la période de crise il faut aussi
savoir ren au dispositifs de chèque je
trouve que ça fait partie du mécanisme
de sortie de crise donc je préfère un
ajustement plus progressif sans chèque
qu'un ajustement plus brutal avec chèque
donc c'est vrai une vraie divergence
c'est une vraie divergence entre nous je
veux pas le je ne le je ne le je ne le
cache pas d'autre part les ménages
modestes parlons-en jamais il a été
question d'enlever le chèque annuel et
pérenne pour aider les foyers les plus
modestes à faire face à leur dépenses
d'énergie qui couvre à peu près 6
millions de personnes ce chè là il
demeure il était il existait avant même
la crise he il existait
avant il existait avant même la crise et
donc le chèque j'essaie
d'estimer le chèque que vous propose le
rapporteur général qui fera l'objet du
débat en partie 2 on l'a bien compris ça
sera au BAMO selon nos calculs tout
dépendra du paramètre c'est au moins 3 4
milliards d'euros 3 4 milliards d'euros
et après il va falloir sortir encore de
ce chèque exceptionnel moi je pense que
psychologiquement c'est le discours
qu'on tient avec le maire nous devons
refermer la période exceptionnelle que
nous avons traversé et la fin d'échec
fait partie de la fermeture de cette
période exceptionnel donc voilà notre
divergence c'est ça nous avons pris
l'engagement vid français pas
d'augmentation pas d'augmentation de
plus 10 % des prix d'électricité nous
souhaitons tenir cet engagement là je
pense qu'en terme de finances publiques
nos deux options sont à peu près
équivalentes en terme d'économie le
chemin que vous proposez est différent
du notôtre voilà tout merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général euh je vous redis le le
solde vous parlez monsieur le ministre
enfin notre Assemblée a besoin d'être
éclairé le
solde pour nous par rapport à votre
dispositif on propose de sortir pour un
coup pour les finances publiques d'un
milliard d'économie parce que vous vous
vous prenez les les les comment
dirais-je les données de manière brute
vous dites c'est blanc ou c'est noir
nous on vous dit c'est pas blanc ou noir
on a une somme d'argent et on regarde
sur quel comment dirais-je quel levier
utiliser et dans les leviers à utiliser
on pense quand même que puisqu'il faut
sortir du dispositif il vaut mieux le
faire par une compensation à l'endroit
des personnes dont les revenus sont soit
très faibles soit de ce que on appelle
dans les classes moyennes et on prend le
Paris de proposer au ménag plus aisé ou
très aisé
d'être de ne plus bénéficier d'aide ça
s'appelle donc finalement une sortie
progressive mais dès le départ c'estd
que on sort de de de l'uniformité que
votre dispositif mais non mais bien sûr
que si avec le chèque le chèque il va
permettre une sortie différenciée là
vous restez sur tous au même niveau même
combat aveugle je suis désolé de vous
dire Monsieur le Ministre enfin écoute
z- nous partez sur le le dispositif
qu'on propose aujourd'hui parce que il
est un atout et puis vous nous dites le
chèque il faut en sortir alors Dieu sait
si on n pas été des adeptes du chèque
tousazimut oui mais mais on accepte de
regarder les choses en ciblant
souvenez-vous du chèque je crois c'était
le chèque carburant qui était promis qui
devait coûter 1 milliard et demi ou 1
milliard 2 et finalement qui n'a coûté
de mémoire que autour de 500
millions qu'est-ce que ça démontre
peut-être aussi en creux j'ai pas la
certitude parce que j'ai pas les moyens
de contrôler c'est que quand on adresse
deschecs pour un peu plus d'un milliard
et que finalement il y en a à peine la
moitié qui en bénéficie c'est que les
personnes peut-être considèrent que le
montant est pas assez élevé enfin ne
prennent pas la peine d'utiliser le
chèque et ben je pense que ça vaut le
coup je dirais de privilégier notre
proposition qui est une qui est le début
d'une sortie qui permet je le redis de
responsabiliser tout le monde et dans la
responsabilisation on fait le pari que
c'est plus simple d'accepter de sortir
en sifflé ou progressivement pour les
ménages les plus aisés ou très aisés que
pour celles et ceux qui n'ont pas le
choix voilà le choix qu'on fait c'est un
choix économique écologique social c'est
un choix qui est un choix finalement
plein d'humanité merci monsieur
Montauger merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
euh la question est éminemment
structurelle égard à la question des des
tarifs et si l'on veut être équitable à
l'égard de l'ensemble des catégories de
cons de consommateurs des plus modestes
comme on dit jusqu'au jusqu'aux
industriels par
exemple il faut que les coûts et donc
les tarifs résultent
du mix énergétique national le plus
possible voilà le système de marché
décorrèle beaucoup
trop la formation des prix de la prise
en compte des coûts du mix énergétique
national il y a derrière ça un enjeu de
souveraineté nationale et bien sûr un
enjeu d'équité à l'égard de l'ensemble
des consommateurs et en particulier des
plus modestes c'est c'est ça la question
de fond elle est structurelle et tant
qu'on ne reviendra pas à ce type de
principe on ne s'en sortira pas on on
continuera à faire des chèqus voilà sans
forcément résoudre les problèmes de fond
et en particulier les difficultés
auxquelles sont sont
euh confrontés merci sont confrontés les
plus modestes de de de nos concitoyens
c'est ça la question donc au nom de mon
groupe je je je propose enfin je vous
indique que nous nous abstiendrons parce
que ni l'amendement de la commission ni
celui du gouvernement ne règle de
manière structurelle et sur le fond la
question merci Monsieur montuger Madame
Goulet
oui monsieur le Président je voudrais
simplement dire que sur ce sujet qui est
qui est important à l'initiative de
notre collègue Vincent de lae je pense
que notre groupe va utiliser le droit de
tirage pour une commission d'enquête sur
le prix de l'électricité parce que à un
moment il va falloir appeler un chat un
chat et et et voir comment tout ça se
décompose je pense que les uns et les
autres on sera beaucoup plus éclairé une
fois que le président de laae aura
rempli sa mission et et sa commission
d'enquête merci je crois que nous allons
mettre mettre nous allons mettre au voix
vous parlez une dernière fois Monsieur
le Ministre parce que c'est vrai que c
cet amendement est extrêmement important
je cela fait plus de 20 minutes que nous
sommes
dessus merci monsieur le Président mais
je tiens non non mais attendez attendez
c'estmi le président là il importe vous
vous êtes exprimé vous allez vous
réexprimer et après je mettrai au votes
alors rapidement s'il vous plaît je je
merci monsieur le Président je suis là
pour expliquer et répondre au rapporteur
général et je pense qu'il faut éclairer
la représentation nationale et et le
Sénat je reviens sur cette histoire de
chèque bien regardez vous savez que ce
que vous proposez ce que vous apprêtez à
voter une augmentation je le redit de 20
% du du prix de l'électricité en février
pour les ménages et en moyenne 260 € par
les chèqu qui ont été mis les chèqu
exceptionnel à partir du 3e 4e décil 3e
4e décil on gagne même pas le SMIC hein
c'était un chèque de 100 €. donc le
reste à charge va être très important et
s il ne doit pas être très important si
vous voulez couvrir les classes moyennes
il va coûter des milliards d'euros mais
pas 3 qu probablement beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus sinon voyez entre 100 € et
260 € vous avez 160 € de de reste à
charge et si voulez les couvrir je pense
que à la fin nous ne ferons aucune
économie et je le redis non vous ne
ferez pas plus d'économie que nous et
nous allons nous retrouver avec un
dispositif de chèque dont il sera très
difficile de sortir alors même que nous
devons et nous le répétons ici sortir du
du quoi qu'il en coûte je vous remercie
monsieur le Président m'avoir laissé
l'occasion de répondre au rapporteur
général merci je vais mettre au voix
donc l'amendement 209 de la commission
des finances qui a reçu un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté